so when you think a deliberate thought
of what you want then Law of Attraction
will employ the universe and all people
circumstances and events to move you to
what you've asked for and to move what
you've asked for to you and so if you
think about that there is just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people's circumstances
and events manipulate all of them to
receive what you want and if you really
reflect well on your life and things
that have happened in your life you'll
kind of see that actually that happened
for me all I did was move to here or all
I did was move to there and I received
what I wanted and what you think about
is what you get what you focus on is
what will manifest in your life thoughts
come re-energize them and then they will
manifest unless we cancel that thought
out with another thought whether thought
the country big set hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today this is your
best believe life and learn the mindset
shift to make to activate the Law of
Attraction enjoy
I want to talk to you about the secret
when we made the sacred documentary
because the sacred documentary reached
hundreds of millions of people across
the planet now it's impossible for me
and the sacred team
to have got the movie Personally into
the hands of those hundreds of millions
of people
and I want you to know what we did with
the secret because
this is a perfect example and may help
you for manifestation in your life
hi everybody on Facebook
hi from India
so much love to everybody there too
thank you so much for joining me
so now we visualized
we visualize the secret bringing joy to
Millions we visualized we intended we
held that dream in our mind constantly
while we were making the documentary I
can say from my perspective
that I held that dream of the Sacred
bringing Joy to the World 24 7. every
breath that I took is that dream was
held and um and we had we actually had
intention meetings every morning at 11
A.M the entire team came together and we
all together collectively saw the sacred
sweeping the world we saw the secret
being featured on Oprah we did all of
everything that you saw happen in the
world we had intended every single day
in Our intention meetings
um so then yes we took action to make
the documentary but I want to explain to
you the difference because of what we
did
the action that we took was to receive
what we had asked for
so
let me think of an example so there were
many teachers that I wanted to have
featured in The Secret and we were based
in Australia at that time the whole team
and I came to the United States we did
not have one single teacher lined up not
one there was one teacher that I really
really wanted I'd read every one of his
books that was Bob Proctor another
teacher that I really really wanted was
Jack Canfield and my sister was
contacting all of the teachers and
um telling them the story my story of
how I had discovered the secret and what
we wanted to do and so
she hadn't had any luck with Bob Proctor
but she had with Jack Canfield and Jack
Canfield happened to be in Aspen and
said and and told us fly to Aspen and oh
oh you can film me and and then he said
he wanted me to do a presentation he had
a big kind of
um meeting that he was holding in Aspen
and he with a lot of teachers and he
wanted me to do a presentation to all of
those teachers I'd never done that
before before in my life but anyway I
showed the trailer and I did a
presentation and I was
I can remember that day that that night
I was just
knew that this is just going to be the
most incredible thing in the world
because this would
set people free and they would be able
to have the life that they deserved and
so I did the presentation
and and Jack Canfield said
announced to the room if anybody would
like to be filmed for this documentary
step forward now and the whole room step
forward all these teachers we just went
there to film Jack Canfield but all of
these teachers do you see how incredible
that is that could never have happened
if we hadn't intended and saw the
universe moved people circumstances and
events for us to receive what we had
asked for now let me tell you about Bob
Proctor because while we're filming in
Aspen my sister finally managed to talk
to Bob Proctor's personal assistant and
and so my sister explained my story
because when the teachers heard my story
they knew that I was authentic and so
she she explained my story and Bob
Proctor's assistant said where are you
now and my sister said we're filming in
Aspen and she's said oh my God
we are here in Aspen
and so do you know when she went and
told Bob Proctor he knew
because we were filming in Aspen and he
was already an aspirin he knew this was
meant to be and he was over sitting in
the chair to be filmed within a couple
of hours and so we filmed Bob Proctor
and that I can tell you is just one of
the tiniest things that happened with
the making of the secret documentary
everything that we needed came to us and
and I remember the team we would say we
could make a movie about the making of
the secret documentary because there
were just so many incredible stories but
all of this that happened everything
that happened for us because was because
we saw it in our mind we saw the joy
that was going to come to the world and
we never ever let go of that and
everything we needed technically
teachers content
um footage whatever we needed was
effortless for us and so if you ask any
one of the Sacred team if thought is
more powerful than action
then we know it is the case we know it
rule number two is visualize with Bob
Proctor Dr Warner Von Braun when
President Kennedy asked him what it
would take to build a rocket that would
carry a man to the moon and then bring
him back safely to Earth Von Braun said
the will to do it the will is the mental
faculty that gives you the ability to
hold one ID on the screen of your mind
to the exclusion of all outside
distractions
see
if you take your imagination
do it you have goals take your
imagination and then take yourself there
see yourself already have completed the
goal
and then hold that picture with your
will
when you go there with your imagination
there is a place
whatever it is you want you went there
with your imagination there is a place
you stay there in your imagination
you will attract everything that's
required for the manifestation of that
picture
you saw Brady doing it last Sunday
yeah as a machine yeah
absolutely phenomenal
so holding the imagination the picture
that you want in your mind and then
attracting it on the steps to get yeah
you see
we don't work toward the goal we work
from the goal you get the goal in your
mind
our problem is we measure everything on
the physical
and yeah you look at the physical and
you say well I haven't got it yet
if you think your conscious mind
if you get an image there
of your goal you've already got it
intellectually
if you didn't have it you couldn't share
it with me but if you have it you can
share it with me
you can share with me the idea that
you've got in your mind so you've
already got it there haven't you
right as you get emotionally involved
with that idea you've got it also on an
emotional level
you've got it there you've got it
intellectually you've got it emotionally
the only place you haven't got it is
physically
now right there's a period of time must
elapse
for that idea that you have
intellectually and emotionally for that
idea to move into physical form
we understand how much time pardon
how much time does it usually take we
don't know we don't know that's the only
thing we don't know is that gestation
period for an idea we know what the
gestation period is for wheat
we know what it is for a carrot we know
what it is for a baby
moment of conception it's about 280 days
we didn't always know these things
but we do now
we don't know what the gestation period
is for a spiritual seed and that's what
an idea is
but it grows by exactly the same law
and so if we hold that idea in our mind
it must by law manifest in form it moves
into Farm now that is called the
Perpetual transmutation of energy
it's one of the laws of the universe
rule number three is learn to delay
gratification with Marissa Pierre you
may have heard any many times about the
marshmallow test and the marshmallow
test is an interesting test where they
took children who put them in a room
with one marshmallow it's also be done
with one cookie and one prep so
and they said to the children if you
wait
don't eat that marshmallow then you will
have two so they were seeing how good
these children were at delaying
gratification because if you can delay
gratification you are wide for success
and they found one group maybe a third
of the kids just shoved that marshmallow
in their mouth straight away and said oh
I couldn't wait I needed it now they
needed instant gratification the second
group said no I'm gonna wait and they
sat there knowing that if they waited
they got two marshmallows the third
group well they were interesting because
they they really wanted that marshmallow
they were very much a combination group
wanted to they wanted it
and they also wanted to wait as they
made funny faces they turned their chair
around they tried not to look at the
marshmallow and they forced themselves
to wait and they also got the second
marshmallow so group one instant
gratification group two naturally
delayed gratification groups three were
kind of programmed to be group one but
fought with themselves until they became
group two they resisted their natural
instinct to eat the marshmallow and what
they discovered is they followed those
children was group two and three the
ones who delayed gratification naturally
or
completely unnaturally were way way more
successful in group one that when I need
it and I can't wait and I got no
self-control it looks nice it tastes
nice bam I've eaten it and now I kind of
wish I'd waited
so I'm telling you this because
it does not matter if you are not
naturally grouped too it only matters
that you can train yourself teach
yourself and help yourself to become
group two
because here's the thing when we're kids
we learn naturally to delay
gratification our parents say clean your
room and then you can have an ice cream
do your homework and then you can go to
the park
do your chores and then we'll go out and
have cookies
we all do that naturally with children
and then we learn to stop and you see if
you come in from work and you are
naturally a gratification delay you'll
go where are my favorite program is on
tonight and I'm going to have this
wonderful dinner but first I'm going to
go through my emails do the stuff that's
important and then my dinner movie is my
reward and what happens is you get
through the way you don't do because
you're thinking of the rewarding of this
is a reward for doing that other people
come in and go no I'm going to watch a
movie I'm going to have a lovely dinner
and later I do my emails and of course
later never comes because you had your
reward first and it is a classic mistake
to take your reward first now when I do
things I don't want to do I start to say
okay I'm going to do this and then I'm
going to make a phone call I'm going to
do this and then I'm going to have a
wonderful coffee even having a coffee a
tea a Nutribullet I think I need that
but first i'm going to do something and
then I'm going to reward myself with
that
[Music]
and I've wired my brain now to do work
first take the rewards second and very
rarely to have the reward first and then
do the work because I know it doesn't
work if I take the reward first I don't
do the work and also human beings are
wired to like a reward if you talk to
any guys they say that they like women
that make them work for their attention
they don't really like them they just
give it all away because they need to
earn it they like to earn love earn
respect earn admiration we don't really
like or we haven't worked for
I went with so many rock stars that just
give everything away and take drugs and
fall apart because they go yeah but I
just wrote a song and I never earned
that we are actually wired as humans to
like to earn our reward and we feel so
good and we earned it and we go I earned
that I deserve that I was worthy when
someone just gives us stuff
it actually has no value I know when I
work with companies sending me lots of
clients to stop smoking
and the success rate wasn't high enough
because they were just giving it away
when I said look you need to make your
staff pay and then you reimburse them
after a year then it will work and when
they did that the success rate changed
dramatically because they were earning
getting their stopping smoking Fizz back
from the company but they have to show
some commitment to so please remember
you are hardwired to earn your reward to
feel really good about enjoying
something you have earned and when you
take the reward without earning it it
makes you feel terrible which is why so
many of my clients get into destructive
Behavior drugs drinking procrastination
self-loathing because we can't
appreciate stuff that we're just given
we like it much more when we earn it do
I naturally take gratification
[Music]
or my group two do I earn it I'm a group
three am I going to learn to earn it you
can learn to delay gratification
why yourself to delay gratification
because it is another thing that you do
that will allow you to join the success
Club delay gratification you are on your
way to success and guess what success is
on its way to you because what you are
moving towards
is simultaneously moving towards you
faster when you learn to delay
gratification also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is focus on the good
things with Jack Canfield one of the
most powerful forces in the universe
surrounds us affects us and if
approached consciously and intentionally
can be used to positively impact our
future
and like gravity it's not something we
can turn on and off it just is and like
gravity we can choose to fight it we can
complain about it or we can harness this
tremendous benefits just as successful
people do and I'm talking about the law
of attraction
State on its most basic form the Law of
Attraction says what you think about
talk about believe strongly about and
feel intensely about you will bring
about
simply put the Law of Attraction says
that you will attract into your life
whatever you focus on whatever you give
your energy and attention to will come
back to you so if you stay focused on
the good and the positive things in your
life you'll automatically attract more
good and positive things into your life
and if you're focused upon lack and
negativity then that is what will be
attracted into your life
so here are three steps to help activate
the law of attraction in your life
step one is to ask for what you want not
for what you don't want
because the Law of Attraction states
that you'll attract into your life
whatever you give your energy focus and
attention to wanted or unwanted it
doesn't care so you must be more
deliberate about what you think and feel
about
The Law of Attraction also states that
each thought or feeling you offer
carries with it of vibrational frequency
to which the universe responds by giving
you more of whatever you're vibrating it
doesn't care whether the request is good
for you or not it simply responds to
your vibration
so to become more intentional about your
thoughts that you offer the universe
you'll need to decide what you want
but also practice feeling those emotions
you'll experience when you have it
perhaps you want to change careers
move to another state when a major
professional award you have your own TV
show or recover from a major illness
how would you feel once you've arrived
at your goal
what would you be doing throughout your
day who would you be spending your time
with
now the more you focus on and talk about
what you do want instead of what you
don't want the faster you will manifest
your dreams and your goals
now step two is to believe that you'll
get what you want and then take action
what does it mean to believe you'll get
what you want it means maintaining a
positive expectancy going about your day
with certainty knowing that you've put
your future in the hands of powers that
are greater than yours now of course
once you believe that you'll get what
you want the second part of the equation
is to take action taking the actions
that would create your desired result
affirms your belief that what you want
is Within Reach it adds to the power of
your expectation
a step three step three is to receive
what you want by becoming a vibrational
match for it in order to receive that
which you are intending you must become
a vibrational match for what you want to
attract into your life
and the easiest way to become a
vibrational match to what you want is to
focus on creating the positive emotions
of love
Joy appreciation and gratitude
throughout your day because those are
the feelings you'd have if you'd already
achieved all your goals
now you can also practice feeling the
emotions you'll be experiencing if you
already have what you wanted maybe
driving that car and you're feeling
powerful or you're on the beach and
you're feeling relaxed but feel it right
now when you're visualizing it it's
called acting as if
now I want to leave you with a bit of
homework to complete when you're done
watching this video begin to focus on
the things that you do want in life
rather than the things you don't want
and resolve to think positively about
all things to hold yourself accountable
rule number five is do the work with Mel
Robbins that's only true that you can
think good things and have good things
happen if you do the work to make those
good things happen the thinking's just
the first part you got to actually take
the actions that are inspired by the
thinking and the second thing that
people do in terms of being sold a bill
of goods is that you kind of have been
led to believe that if you create a
vision board and you plaster up on the
vision board images of beach houses and
Lamborghinis and nfts and millions of
dollars in the bank and the world's
skinniest body and all the things that
you would love to have magically appear
in your life that simply creating the
vision is enough
the reason why that's a mistake is
because research shows that simply
envisioning the end goal without
actually imagining all the steps that
lead you there and without training your
body to feel what it's going to feel
like to do the hard work
simply Imagining the end goal isn't
motivating at all
it's pretty inspiring for about a day
but then what happens is that you start
to stare at the beach house and the
million dollars in the bank and you will
feel discouraged
because you'll realize holy cow
from where I sit
there's an impossible
gap between my studio apartment or
living in my parents basement and the
beach house that I want there's an
impossible gap between the fact that my
divorce basically left me bankrupt and
now I'm staring at a vision board with a
million dollars in the bank
holy cow I've got 150 pounds to lose and
I'm gonna stare at my photo from when I
was my you know best weight when I was a
high school division one athlete no
staring at the end goal is not only a
mistake it's profoundly discouraging
it's the reason why so many people fail
to reach their goals because they only
set their goals and they never do the
part that's the most important and
that's where manifesting comes in
manifesting helps you do the work
manifesting done properly is preparing
you to do all the things between where
you are and where you want to get to so
I'll give you an example
let's say that up on your vision board
okay up on your vision board is the fact
that you want to launch your own
business right now you work for somebody
else you can't stand what you do you
have panic attacks when you wake up
because you know that you're headed in
the wrong direction you've always
dreamed of opening a bakery and so you
slap up a vision board and you've got
this big visual up on your wall that you
stare at every morning of this beautiful
bakery that you've always dreamed of
higher of starting here's the problem
you have no money you have no savings
you've never started a business before
how the hell are you going to get this
done
staring at the vision board gives you
panic attacks here's how manifesting is
going to help
manifesting is where instead of staring
at the photos of the bakery
you see
feel and eventually start to believe
that you can do the work to make it a
reality
and so what you're going to manifest is
you're going to manifest all the steps
from point A which is starting at zero
all the way to point Z
which is opening the doors
you're gonna see yourself and notice I'm
closing my eyes this is because
manifesting is a habit manifesting
happens here in your mind and in your
heart and your body I want you to see
yourself
instead of going out tonight with your
friends see yourself staying in and
watching videos videos on YouTube
of other people that have opened
bakeries
see yourself going to the library and
getting a book
that tells the story of somebody who did
it see yourself taking webinars and
tutorials about how to raise the money
to do something like this see yourself
studying Kickstarter campaigns of other
people who have launched a bakery and
raised money through Kickstarter
campaigns see yourself talking to people
who have done this see yourself talking
to friends and family see yourself
taking a class in it see yourself
staying in next weekend and working on
this see yourself getting a part-time
job in a bakery and learning behind the
scenes because you've always dreamed of
doing this but you've never worked in
one
and One Vision at a time as you feel
yourself being tired as you feel the
late nights as you feel yourself doing
the work with no timeline you'll start
to believe
that you're gonna do it and that will
keep you inspired to take those little
actions to do it and that way when you
come in after a long day and you've
spent the day watching a webinar or
watching a YouTube video or you had a
conversation with somebody that gave you
some advice when you walk into your room
and you see that beautiful vision board
you know what's going to happen your
mind and your body and spirit will
literally start to buzz because what
you've been rehearsing in your mind body
and spirit through visualization aligns
with it that's how you do it simply
envisioning the end game that's a
one-way ticket to being discouraged
unmotivated and stuck
you start to use manifesting properly
you start to visualize every single step
of the way and you will be training for
it and doing the work to make it happen
and that is motivating angle number six
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is watch your thoughts with
Lisa Nichols your life is a physical
manifestation
of the conversation going on in your
head
I'm gonna start with that can we just
speak for like 24 hours on this I love
this right your life is a physical
manifestation of the conversation going
on in your head so if you
everything your life is going to show up
to make your thoughts true so you have
one job you have one job in your life
for you to make what you think about
life true so that you're not wrong you
don't want to walk around wrong wrong
wrong wrong wrong wrong you want to be
right about the life you see so you're
going to work hard work hard to produce
the life that you talk about in your
mind whether that life is no one loves
me I'm all alone you can be in a group
of people and you will think I'm so
alone
and and you will feel alone and things
will show up to co-sign your loneliness
just because you're looking for that and
so
um if you start with I'm gonna say the
mind like the mind is that thing the
mind is the core engine it starts all
things it shuts all things down when I
start thinking something different like
hold on stop I want to think something I
shut down that behavior I shut down that
outcome when I birth something I birthed
it in my mind I focus on my mind I see
myself there in my mind before I got on
with you I was doing guided
visualizations
I'm recording them so people and I I
mean they're juicy and I'm saying see
yourself here because if you can see it
and then the the the key is evoke the
emotion as if you were there yeah right
and that's why people are who are sad
all the time are sad because they're
thinking of things that make them sad
and then the emotion follows the thought
so I'm gonna say everything starts with
your thought Louis but let me just say
this when you speak
you speak your future into the world you
speak your view whatever you say
whatever falls off your tongue when when
you say I am
right the unconscious mind says and you
are so whatever comes on the other side
of that and so you you you ask me a hard
question which one is most important it
starts with the thought I think the
thought is the that's where everything
originates and then you add a whole lot
of turbo boost to it with your tongue
yeah but when you align the two
and then you add to it like the B12 the
B12 of action action is like action is
like that's the Nitro that's the Nitro
like
right and I see so many people they
think it they write it they Journal it
they talk about it and they do no action
and I go you understand that the action
is that that's like that's like putting
the flower in the sun because it
requires something so yeah yeah I had it
it's a beautiful explanation and I had a
Navy SEAL on uh I don't know six seven
months ago his name is Chad and he
he talked about as a seal uh he he used
the tongue as a Rudder in a boat he said
what you speak is going to lead you down
you know the ocean or the river or
wherever on the boat you're on and so he
never says anything negative out loud
because it's so powerful and the Navy
Seals you talk about how powerful it is
no matter how much pain they're
experiencing in hell week and all this
stuff they're dealing with they never
allow the tongue to speak something
negative otherwise they'll ultimately
quit and give up right right right too
painful to deal with what they deal with
right to then say Oh I'm hurting I'm
tired I can't do it right right don't
don't don't speak that don't speak that
into the array you just because whatever
you speak feels like it expands of
course right energy Grows Where energy
goes it expands so Speak Life speak
possibility there is not one dark
situation that doesn't have a glimmer of
light it doesn't mean it's going to be
convenient to see yeah that's true most
of us are looking for convenient light
have you ever spent any time wondering
how does everything happen how does
everything happen why does the night
follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
back in some places it does
but
I spent a lot of time thinking about
this
after times it almost drives me crazy
but on the greater side of my studio
here is a Japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud plume and leaves pop
out and the leaves generally in the
spring are a very deep greeny Brown
they're not a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're the
most beautiful it is the most beautiful
tree and it's right outside of my studio
I'm sitting here on my desk and
the cameras around me but out there is
that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
Every Spring there are greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the faux and greeny brown in the spring
think about it did you ever wonder
why the tide goes way out the tide comes
way back in
I spent some time in the Navy in Canada
I was down on the East Coast for a while
and I was near the Bay of Fundy do you
know the Bay of Fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same upper on Prince George on the West
Coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down that ship goes
way up near and it comes way down very
high very low tide now some place the
Tide's not very big they do have a tide
but not too high not too low
why is it so different in one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer it's a
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know do you ever think about this do
you know that everything in this
universe happens in an exact way
and exactly not by chance but in an
exact way
when John Kennedy the president of the
United States acted as Dr Warner Von
Braun who was The Mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring them back
safely to Earth Ron Brown answered him
in five words the will to do it that's
it the will to do it
he knew he didn't have to know how to do
it he knew he had to learn how to do it
but you didn't have to know to make up
your mind you were going to do it now
why did he say that because he
understands the laws
Von Braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of God and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise that we don't even have any
difficulty building spaceship we send
people to the moon and we can kind The
Landing with the Precision of a fraction
of a second
now he said these lies must have been
set by someone I see the laws as God's
modus operandi but I'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and I get in harmony with the law
now we do that odds are pretty good we
should understand them but when we get
in harmony with the law then I'm going
to tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now I've been doing that for the last
58 years I'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but I don't
understand them as well as I want to or
would like to
but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I'll have to talk to you about this
book
uh that'll be another time
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like what are the laws and
then study them
you know when when we stop expecting
things to be the way that we think they
should be when we stop forcing outcomes
and when we start allowing what is of
the highest good to be our only agenda
our only intention that's when the
universe truly has our back that's when
we can live what it means to surrender
true surrender comes when we stop
praying for what we think we need and we
start connecting and grounding in what
could possibly be of the highest good
for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all so true
manifesting is about receiving what is
of the highest good for all and it
begins not just with what will how will
I get what is of the highest good but
how can I be open to what is of the
highest good how can I open up my
Consciousness to release what I think I
need and get grounded in what is
possible and what is of the highest good
not just for me and my agenda but the
highest good for all that's the message
so you're doing everything right and
that you're open to a spiritual practice
you're willing to grow you're showing up
for your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear Gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
that actually create sort of a manic
manifesting vibration which is how do I
get that what am I what do I do next got
to do this thing next got to do this
thing next and that lacks the belief
system that I can be still and I can
allow
that's number one number two being in
the expectation of what you think things
should be is another block to your
manifesting power and your super
attractor power which is what I call it
because your expectations are limiting
the possibilities your expectations are
limiting the highest good as this card
says so when we start to pray for what
is of the highest good rather than
intend and pray for what we think we
need that's when the universe can
conspire with what it is that is of the
highest good for all so ultimately
what's happening is all the doing doing
doing is energetically blocking and all
the expecting expecting expecting is
blocking the manifestation as well
because when you're in this tunnel
vision of expectation it should be this
way I should be further along I
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible In
This Moment the creative possibility In
This Moment the exciting being potential
In This Moment you're blocking it
blocking it blocking it blocking it
blocking it blocking it
I want you to sit on your ass
I want you to stop doing doing doing
I want you to
start being being
which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbing yourself you said
I want to embody the feeling I want to
embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an action
true manifesting does require us to show
up for our desires you've got to pick up
the phone and then call the job
interview and you have to ask for the
date and you have to to do whatever it
is that you want to create but
ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel I think one of my first things in
failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
can't take that personally because they
didn't meet me in person they didn't
have a interaction with me they just saw
my name they saw I'd been a monk for
three years that resume is useless I
mean what's your transferable skills
like sitting in silence
surprise surprise no one wants to hire a
monk and so they've rejected you but
that's not personal because they didn't
meet me in person but what if they had
me right so that's the first thing the
first step is don't take all fear
failure I'll give an example me and you
we've reached out to countless guests to
be on our podcast we'll say no all the
time we're saying all the time but if I
don't hear a no from the guest directly
that's not a no like someone's team can
say no someone's assistant can say no
someone's PR team can say no but until
they say no personally it's not a no
okay but when they do say no then that's
enough yeah so then let's move how do
you deal with that type of failure yes
so if I deal with a failure where
someone meets me in person and gets to
know no Jay you're horrible you suck
like I don't want to deal with a monk
ever in my life yeah I would never go on
your show I'm never listening to you
never yeah that how do you deal with
that type of so I've had you say this
I've said a couple of times and I'm sure
it's been repeated a bunch of times
around how I genuinely believe failure
has feedback feedback and and so for me
it's like failure has the ability to
actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah with the results you
want the results you want and don't make
that result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah and I think a lot of people can do
that in life but we're so afraid to like
go on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing and they need to
make the fight they didn't make the
finals they lost and then they realized
they need to get the team and they need
to find their I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am
the majority of our thoughts and
feelings are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes a resource of
light and information and we're turning
it into chemistry and we're literally
robbing the body's energy right so so
then living like that for the short term
is okay because the body can move back
to homeostasis and then restore itself
but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain the limbic
brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
Messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as energy in these energy
centers and and if you're living in
survival why would you open your heart I
mean it's just not a time to open your
heart I mean if you're getting chased by
T-Rex it's not a time to meditate it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
connect it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fighter hide and so is
that why we're this way I've never asked
you this before is this some I don't I
don't think you believe this but I just
want to understand is this some sort of
genetic disposition that's been passed
down to us since we've been chased by
T-Rex I think so I think survival has
been very adaptive yeah like because if
you're being chased by T-Rex you don't
run up to T-Rex T-Rex and say oh cute
little dinosaur let me pet you that's
not adaptive the fear is adaptive you
run from the unknown you learn from
challenges right yes so if you're living
in survival there's better chances of
surviving if you run from the unknown
and by the way when you're living in
survival they have the infinite
Potentials in the quantum field you'll
select the worst case scenario in your
mind and you'll begin to emotionally
prepare yourself for the worst case
scenario because you have better chances
of surviving there you go if you prepare
for the worst right so people spend
their whole life yes thinking about the
worst thing and emotionally embracing it
while you take a thought and emotion or
an image and an emotion you're your
branding or conditioning your body into
what anxiety into fear so then you keep
doing that over and over again over and
over again your the body becomes the
mind of fear and whether you think you
can control it or not you're gonna have
a panic attack and the panic attack is
the body saying you've conditioned me
this way try as you may with your
conscious mind and control it right you
programmed it subconsciously then you
start worrying about the next panic
attack and it's that very anticipation
it keeps the person on the hamster wheel
it robs them of all of this energy as
well they're absolutely so so they don't
believe
impossibility when they're living in
that state because in survival it's not
a time to create all the blood flows
going to the hindbrain and away from the
forebrain there's no there's there's no
physiology really for a person to begin
to create a new future so then so think
about it so then 70 of the time people
in the world are living anticipating the
next moment based on their past moment
and so they're laying reality down
Moment by moment with the next known the
next predictable moment and so the
hormones of stress endorse the senses
our senses become heightened when we're
under stress and we become materialists
we narrow our focus on the danger yes so
then you're focusing on matter you're
focusing on the material world and when
you do that you put all your attention
the arousal of the stress hormones puts
all your attention on your body if
you're being chased by T-Rex you better
be paying attention to your body
consistent action is the cure-all
whatever problem you have whatever issue
you're facing whatever big life you want
to create for yourself the way to get
there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get to almost two million
subscribers and I was sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I had my camera guy and my assistant
and we're filming and the electricity
goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film with this like electricity
outage and then fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you've you have had an idea that you've
loved that you gave up on too soon that
if you just kept doing it this is an
idea that you had maybe three years ago
that if you just found the way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well still work
on vacation first off it's not work like
I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody uh one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend
2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
just not being intentional that's the
problem if you feel like you got to the
end of the week and you were so busy but
you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you
wanted a life whatever your dream life
looks like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what I can make
right now if I'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what I can make
out of the hospital but I'm going to
make the best of what I can make right
now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
on your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're going to the next
day wake up I'm not I can't do that I'm
not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and says it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're going to do that's why
it's important to create a realistic
calendar don't tell me don't tell
yourself you're going to make 100 videos
a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring you people like John Ashraf and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions to your
ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
[Music]
this funny video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for the seven habits to activate
the Law of Attraction check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there if you look at this for a
moment
I think the Neville put it very well he
said you're only limited by weakness of
attention and Poverty of imagination